oh my god i just want to take his head
i'm going to peel the skin off of his
skull i know where you're going i wanted
to start throwing it up like pizza dough
until it's long flat and round and i
want to take it to a picnic
and toss it around like a frisbee at a
puppy-faced frisbee picnic
oh hold on a second
oh hell no he did not
just text me he working late that it's
weak
okay you know what working late my ass
if you don't walk through that door in
the next half an hour
he knows when i can come home tonight
cause i'm not gonna be there waiting
for his cheating ass okay hey
you know what i'm saying i mean i will
be there waiting because
but he gonna have to put up with a lot
of from me okay
and if he then he gonna do this again
he is sorely mistaken oh cause my man
gets one chance oh no one okay and then
after that he get one more
okay and then after that he gonna get
three strikes
and you're out okay if i ever find out
that my man was messing around on me
he better get as far away from me as he
possibly can because he do not want to
get
what i'm gonna give to him okay i got my
mother
real estate license okay but if and when
he does come home that's fine okay
cause he can go out and get all turned
up with these little side hoes and
whatnot
cause you know what [ __ ] he always
gonna come home
all right okay i'm the queen bee and he
always gonna come home not to me you
know
but i'll tell you what happened if you
do come home okay he ain't gonna be
pulling any that
in my house okay man he can come to
house if he wants to
but he ain't never gonna do that when
i'm home all right
you know what even if i'm home it's fine
you know what i'm talking about okay
cause i don't give a good guy damn
okay that's what i'm talking about but
he ain't gonna bring that into my
bedroom
i'll tell you that much right now okay
cause they know try finesse they're
gonna wake me up
while he's cheating on me in my bed
again
okay and i told him i looked it right in
the face
i said this is the fifth and last time
i couldn't have said it better myself
though you're right okay
you just been spouting words of wisdom
all evening and i ain't listening to a
damn thing you saying
i don't even know what the hell i was
thinking girl you're right
the second that that man walks through
that door
i'm gonna dump his hands oh okay
okay okay oh my gosh speak of the devil
oh okay
okay i love it this is amazing it's
amazing
i got like four stars somewhere already
i got six stars just like in possible oh
my god let's take a picture take a
picture right now okay here we go
oh my god i'm making a video one big
nose is deleted
what am i doing why am i looking at an
orca whale deleted
oh my god what's my eye doing ooh i look
like i'm 40.
[ __ ] your weapon
oh i totally look like cloverfield just
have a stroke or something
right yeah oh we're
cute now ladies can you just show me the
picture you were talking about oh it's
like
yeah stop great right there that's great
rick grady we got a clear shot of the
perpetrator he's holding the shotgun and
everything
look where'd the picture go we deleted
it what i had childbirth phase yeah it
looked like my grandmother having an
orgasm
delete it grady book these idiots for
destroying evidence
ow ew why are you being so manhandling
elitist why are we even we were the
heroes of the evening
we stopped the perpetrator now we're
being arrested oh my god
guy you cannot you cannot arrest me with
that picture are you kidding me
delete it it's blinking this is
ridiculous delete it right now
delete it delete
but when she does talk like you're
listening yeah oh my gosh last time i
was like who are you you're brilliant
[Music]
that is the cutest effing puppy i've
ever seen my entire life oh my god
i'm just gonna take him and i just want
to bite his little ears off i just want
to take his little legs and just like
snack on him like little like like
chicken drummettes yeah i just want to
take his fuzzy little perfect head i
want to put it in my mouth and squeeze
down on it hard until i have a puppy
face diamond
in my mouth i feel like i have to wrap
his face in a towel and then beat it
with a tire iron i'm going to buy that
dog i'm going to drive him to the vet
and i'm going to have him put down
immediately oh my god you know what i'm
going to have to do
i'm going to have to take that scrubby
little nose yeah and just kick it i just
have to i wouldn't
kick it until it comes off on my shoes
like little puppy snout slippers
and then i'm gonna go to a party and
it's like oh my god where'd you get
those slippers like these these are my
face slippers my adorable dumb little
pudding that's
exactly what i was going to say oh my
god i just want to take his head and i'm
going to peel the skin
off of his skull i know where you're
going i want to just start throwing it
up like pizza dough
until it's long flat and round and i
want to take it to a picnic
and toss it around like a frisbee at a
puppy-faced frisbee picnic let's get out
yeah
so cute so cute oh my god is it me or is
it like totally mosquitoey out here
oh my god remember this one it was so
cute
so i'm doing this like airline food diet
it's like all i eat and i've lost like
16 hats oh my god amy i almost forgot to
tell you
we got a new receptionist at work ew no
way yeah so i'm in the common area alone
minding my own business yeah oh she said
something to you she came up to me and
no joke she's like
hi i'm sandy i don't believe we've met
yet oh she said that to you
no amy i'm not even kidding you she's
crazy um
yeah no like i'm scared like crazy
like get this [ __ ] away from me she's
psychopathically bat [ __ ] crazy oh my
god that totally reminds me i have a new
neighbor
ew yeah she comes over my house she
knocks in the door with like a
package under her arm um stalker match
um
yeah and she looks me in the eye and she
says to me um excuse me i think
the postman dropped this package off at
my house by accident she said that to
you
yeah crazy bad i mean like i'm gonna
have to move because this bitch's nut
burgers make looney tunes
stand at the foot of my bed with a knife
crazy oh my god that totally reminds me
oh yeah you remember that girl at
starbucks the crazy one no a different
one she's new i haven't met her yet well
she's crazy
uh-huh she gives me my change and then
she's like thanks
bye she smiled at you like that
how crazy is that that's like that's
like insane in the membrane crazy like
like this is the membrane she's inside
of it because that's insane no like i'm
not even kidding you amy that's crazy
like it puts the lotion in the basket or
else it gets the hose again cray to the
mother
cray yeah like if jay-z had a sister her
name would be cray hey
you ladies want to meet channing tatum
oh
is he really in there serious oh tanning
why danny what are you doing in a van
you're effing crazy i don't see you
channing why are you hiding in here
shanny are you like in a little ball it
smells like mildew in here
ow sharp jagged rusty ass is that a meat
hut
okay i don't care which situation
situation don't care and i'm trying to
help people not over
no okay you know what jquery is no i
don't know what
you need to think about yourself
sometimes before you start insinuating
yourself and other people bidding
well you know what denies i'm gonna
insinuate my stuff whenever and wherever
i please cause it's a free country
[ __ ]
okay you know what oh we're doing this
okay so we're gonna do here babe
yeah we are about to fight now bring it
on there
let's go i ain't even playing
no i would love for you to step to me i
really would appreciate just talking i
don't
even cause you care no more talking now
and that's all you're doing call me a
[ __ ] again
oh yeah call me a business okay no
i would like to see what happens i would
love to see
what happens oh you do oh absolutely so
why don't you come
and bring it then [ __ ]
see no you are riding my last nerve
and i ain't even playing no more i am
not
even playing no more oh it's all then
let's do
something okay you want to go
do something [ __ ] huh there we go
let's do something
let's do something [ __ ] what
[Music]
we told you not to mess with us [ __ ]
y'all just saw that [ __ ] turn into two
little girls right
oh
happy sunday esther happy sunday
georgina
how was your week oh the lord is with me
mm-hmm
but the devil he got his hands on my
grandniece
grace oh no mm-hmm they're smoking the
reefer and doing the hanky-panky with
boys
no dog or esther you know
that i love all things that are good and
holy
but if he doesn't let go of my
grandniece grace i'm gonna
cut the devil's off and shove it in his
ass
[Music]
with my prayers i know you will joe gina
i know you will how was your week girl
oh you know me i'm blessed and thankful
for everything mm-hmm
all right but you know my grandson jason
got himself
wrapped up in the leathery claws of
satan
not jesus he got himself arrested for
the spray painting and the vandalism oh
lord and i tell you i never
raise my hand in anger but if he don't
let jason go i'm gonna punch that
satan in the nuts so hard and wipe the
licking smirk off his horned ass face
mm-hmm
with my prayers amen i know you will
esther i know you will but esther i
gotta tear you something nice now
oh let it out you know esther that i
have found
serenity in the glory of heaven yes
but my daughter's husband bernard has
got himself
wedged between the cleft hooves and
lucifer herself
she opened up her laptop computer right
and found the pornography of women not
the pornography
absolutely the pornography of women not
on the laptop computer i'm a laptop on
youtube
i am a pacifist under god's request
but if he don't let go of bernard i'm
gonna
sneak up on that [ __ ] ass lucifer
right in the midst of his sleep time and
then i'm gonna sit on that mother
tear and i'm gonna spread my booty
cheeks on that pig's face
and i'm gonna just pucker up my stink
hole and just
that i can use for target practices
with your prayers of course of course oh
georgina georgina georgina
oh i got nothing but faith and god in
heaven above but i
tell you my son's wife crystal she got
herself
wrapped up in the fiery wings of
mephistopheles herself here we go
you know she got caught using profanity
with her own children
what at the dinner table oh launcher
oh i have nothing but love for every
creature on this planet
but if he don't let my darling crystal
go
i'm gonna flirt with the devil oh oh
show him a little bit of shoulder
how you doing he gonna start looking
away i'm gonna start twerking
start twerking he's gonna be like whoa
where he gonna be he's gonna be drawn in
seduce that little
my [ __ ] at him then when at
least expects it
and i got his trust that's when i'm
gonna ride that
i'm gonna give him the night of his life
and now he ain't never gonna forget
don't you don't
give em this way i'm gonna give him that
way and then
right when he about to climax that's
when i'm gonna clinch up my
on that [ __ ] and i'm gonna
snap that off with a divine
kegel well you gotta snap
of course with the prayers yeah but
that's right girl yeah you go get them
out yes
satan him indeed
georgina isn't here anymore
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
who is this crazy [ __ ] now ah it's me
your worst nightmare
i'm on top of you what's going on this
feels good why would you do this to me
oh y'all
[Applause]
oh
please please get these crazy [ __ ]
off of me
jesus christ my personal lord and savior
i swear
oh